all right so we pan across a park
beautiful Park peaceful we see an old
man sitting at a bench feeding ducks
hendon like Grady from Sanford and Son
this is a lot every man will let Cass to
worry about that anyway he's feeding the
dust all of a sudden the dust start
exploding the old man look at the camera
he's been feeding him Seltzer tablets
the whole time he said I told his
goddamn ducks a million times to stop
on my car I set a trap of my
house and cutting my job
I cut the police they say I'm crazy
that's call animal control they go down
they don't control I got their ass
not off that evil ass laughs right then
the old man died of natural causes right
there man on the ground a bunch of blew
up ducks in the old man car on turtle
wash car wax cause you ain't got time
for that